okay welcome back so in the last few
segments we've taken this inverted
pendulum on a cart we have simulated the
full nonlinear system without control
we've linearized about the fixed point
where the pendulums up to get an a
matrix and a D matrix we've checked that
the system is in fact controllable so if
I look at the rank of the
controllability matrix it has dimension
4 so it spans the four dimensional state
space of the position and velocity of
both the carts and the pendulum and then
we've also shown that since the system
is controllable I can design a full
state feedback u equals minus KX so that
I can place the eigenvalues of the
closed-loop system anywhere I want okay
and it's one line in MATLAB where you
specify the eigenvalues and it will find
this gain matrix K - to move your system
to those eigenvalues we then take that
control law apply it to the full
nonlinear system and we show that in
fact we can stabilize this up unstable
inverted pendulum configuration which is
really cool but it begs the question
where do we place the poles where do we
place Augen values where are the best
eggs and that's a really interesting
kind of open-ended question you could
spend a long time trying lots of
different combinations of eigenvalues
and how do you know when you find the
best one so this is just an amazingly
powerful tool in control theory called
the linear quadratic regulator so I'm
going to write it out you have something
called the linear quadratic regulator
that essentially answers this question
linear quadratic regulator or lqr
control and the idea is if I can cook up
a cost function that tells me how how
bad is it if my state is really slow to
converge to where I want it to so if I
make this thing really lightly damp
barely stable it will take forever
to stabilize to move this thing from
point A to point B can I put a cost on
how much that bothers me it how bad that
is if this thing is slow and can I also
put a cost on my actuation you may be it
actually costs fuel or something maybe
it costs energy or you know I have to
buy a bigger beefier motor to make this
thing move really fast into the stable
position so I'm going to build a cost
function it's going to be J equals the
integral now I'm going to integrate from
0 to infinity but really you could just
integrate for a long time from 0 to 10
or 0 to 30 or whatever so I'm going to
integrate from 0 to infinity and what
I'm going to do is I'm going to develop
a matrix Q that is going to tell me how
bad of a penalty it is if X is not where
I tell it to be so this is an N by n
matrix in this case a 4 by 4 matrix and
I'm going to take X transpose QX so this
is you know I want this to be a positive
number so I want Q to be non-negative so
kind of positive semi-definite and I'm
also going to have a similar term u
transpose R U and I'm going to add an X
and u are both functions of T so I'm
going to integrate with respect to T I'm
going to add up these penalties if my
state is not where I tell it to be this
thing's trying to stabilize to zero for
example then this is going to be big ok
so I need this thing to stabilize to
where I tell it to quickly for this to
be small and I want to not spend a lot
of energy doing so or else this is going
to be big and so Q and R are these
matrices so for example if I wanted to
build Q equals let's say 1 1 10 and 100
and zeros everywhere else essentially
what that would do is it would say the
first variable in X which is the
position of the cart I penalize
with one if it's not where I tell it to
be quickly same with X dot this is the
theta dot penalty it's bigger I want I
want my thing to be stabilized in the
vertical position quickly so I'm going
to make this number bigger so that it's
more penalized if it's not where I tell
it to be in the vertical position and
I'm making the theta dot penalty even
larger and you get to play around with
these numbers basically what you do I
might start with the identity matrix and
then if I think that the theta variable
is really important I'm going to bump up
data and theta dot by factors of ten
until I get good performance and four
are maybe in this case you know
electricity is cheap maybe I have a
really beefy electric motor maybe I
overspent my motor and so I'm going to
say R is really small point zero one
basically free I can really actuate this
thing aggressively and so in MATLAB if
you have Q and R it turns out that there
is an optimal K matrix and
honest-to-goodness
best K protocol there's a best control
law that minimizes this cost function
and that's called the linear quadratic
regulator okay so this controller is the
linear quadratic regulator so let's
break it out linear it's a linear
controller it's linear matrix times the
state it's a linear full state feedback
controller
it minimizes a quadratic cost function
if you plot this thing it's a quadratic
cost in the state and the control and it
has a well-defined minimum cost for some
protocol so we're finding the linear
controller that minimizes this quadratic
cost function and regulator just means
this will stabilize my system this
system will be stable so that X will go
to zero okay and if I tell it a
reference value of up and move over you
know four units it will stabilize that
system okay so that's what a linear
quadratic regulator is and again the
great thing in that
is that this is just incredibly easy k
equals
lqr of a B Q and R its decibel so I need
to cook up a Q matrix of an R matrix I
think mine are actually pretty similar
to this I need an a matrix and a B
matrix for the linearization and lqr
will give me the optimum controller for
that cost function with these cost
weights of how much I weight the state
deviations and how much I weigh the
control expenditure okay so we're going
to try this out let's just fire up
MATLAB so again same script except now
this is lqr cart pen so I have the same
parameters for the cart and the pendulum
I have the same a matrix same B matrix
but now you'll see I have a Q matrix
okay so this is exactly my Q matrix my Q
matrix penalize this data and data dot
more than X and X dot and my our matrix
says there's not much of a penalty on
control expenditure controls cheap okay
so I run this one simple command K
equals lqr and that gives me my optimal
state feedback law for this case okay we
run the same code to simulate the
nonlinear system of OD 45 and plot so I
think we're ready to go let's try this
out l QR cart pend enter let's go so it
finds K and it simulates and it does
this nice aggressive stabilization to
that position I told it to so this works
like a dream and in fact I could compute
the I guess be K and see where lqr chose
to place them and so interestingly it
takes one eigenvalue and makes it really
aggressive probably theta dot you know
it's probably corresponds to theta dot
and then the other ones are not so
aggressive and if I wanted to probe this
I actually could I could what would I do
i would look at T comma D equals I of a
minus BK so I get my eigen vectors and
eigen values the
look at let's say the real part of D the
diag of the real parts of D so these are
my eigenvalues the real part and then if
I want to see what the eigenvector
looked like that corresponds to this
most stable eigenvalue all I have to do
is look at the first column of T and
interestingly it actually looks like the
most stabilizing directions are X dot
and theta dot so what this controller is
saying is if I want good performance
you better have really good aggressive
control of X dot and theta dot that's
how that's what you want to be super
fast super aggressive that's got the
biggest negative eigenvalue and I didn't
tell it to do this I just gave it a
weight on how much I want it to converge
and how much I care about control
expenditure and it turned it for me so
there's a lot of stuff I'm glossing over
for example how you actually find the
minimum the K that minimizes this is
very interesting and kind of complicated
so that you could do it with l'orange
multipliers but you can do it by hand
using optimization and then solving for
that K involves solving something called
a riccati equation and so this is
actually expensive for high dimensional
systems this can be I think
order n cubed in the state dimension X
in RN so for example if I'm trying to
control a million by million you know a
million dimensional state system this is
going to be intractable I'm not going to
be able to build an lqr easily for a
million state system ok but for our
little 4 dimensional system really easy
to do this in MATLAB in real time okay
so there's considerations now what I
think is really important to tell you is
when I was cooking up this example and a
few hours doing it I took about an hour
making that nice visualization that
actually plops the pendulum in cool
colors I spent a couple of hours getting
the nonlinear equations and the
linearization that's a
longest time developing the control law
took me less than five minutes okay
getting the control law is the easy part
building a model is the hard part okay
building a model and the linearization
is generally speaking the hard part the
control is incredibly simple in MATLAB
one line it fits in perfectly it's very
clear what it means okay
and if you wanted to play around with
this what I would recommend is try
making are more expenses so let's do
that let's say let's say we're going to
make our actually kind of expensive so
I'm going to save this and run it it's
not going to be as aggressive takes it's
much slower floor and if I look at my
eggs they're a lot less aggressive right
they're different and they're less
aggressive I could make my control
really expensive I could say well I've
got a wimpy motor and electricity super
expensive so I'm going to really
penalize control expenditure and all I
have to do is change that one number and
everything else is exactly the same
that's what I love about control design
especially in MATLAB is if I want to try
a bunch of these things all I have to do
is change you know a couple of numbers
nothing else changes and notice it was
pretty sluggish and my eigenvalues are
now you know even less damped okay so
that's the mile-high overview of lqr we
can see that it actually works on a real
non linear system this inverted pendulum
on a cart very simple to design optimal
in some cost function I didn't tell you
how to derive it but you can look that
up in a book or on on the internet but
it really is optimal linear full state
feedback control with respect to this
quadratic cost function okay
thank you